you were entertaining the idea of going
to
welterweight for for Connor yeah and
then didn't Connor say some stupid thing
like we're gonna fight it middleweight
yeah yeah I mean you know Connor's uh I
guess the way I saw it was so after the
the head kick of Tony Ferguson and the
crazy the crazy postf fight speech that
people love it kind of worked out really
well I think that's what really parlayed
the whole Connor thing I said I wanted
to fight him 170 because he was so big
you know he was you know he was doing
the Roadhouse movie which is finally
going to come out here soon um and he
was big he was beefy and acting like he
was really really big so I was like okay
there's no way he's going to fight 155 I
don't want to fight 155 I weigh like 190
I would love to fight 170 so I figured
I'd do the call out at 170 and then yeah
Connor Connor likes to uh act like he's
in control so he like he could have said
205 and and I would have been like okay
I'll fight you wherever dude like right
because I truly I I'm bigger than Connor
I'm not he's not that big at all he
looks big he's got really great angles
and really great camera uh camera
photography work and Lighting in all of
his photos and stuff I mean I don't know
dude his appearance changed in a mighty
way and uh I mean the him not being in
the usada pool and and uh it being
generally accepted to heal like broken
bones with all kinds of uh you know
steroids um I mean just got a pass for
uh you know taking steroids cuz he broke
his leg is my take on it and he kind of
took that pass and just went way
overboard to where his entire appearance
just went bananas he got big yeah just
his face like uh I mean what the hell I
mean isn't that like a Telltale sign
like your jaw and your forehead get big
yeah I mean and part of that too you
know part of that too cuz I've I've
gained weight and ballooned up after
fights I mean after the gy fight I was I
was nursing all the leg kicks that he
that I took to my lower body and then I
was also the leg kicks that I threw on
him my lower body was kind of trash for
the better part of six weeks so when you
can't do much with your lower body you
know you're going to naturally your
cardio your ability to do cardio goes
down so obviously when Connor was
limping around for what the better part
of a year after two snapped bones he was
naturally going to gain weight but yeah
his the how big his face got yeah but
you're not getting like Bond chin thee
some of those photos you know you can't
help but to think man are they
photoshopped because it's that drastic
or you know jacked he jacked big he was
a big boy but then when I saw him
because you got to remember too he was a
natural 145 pounder I still think he's a
natural 145 pounder I actually made fun
of him saying he has the bone density of
an of an albatross he's got bird bones
like he's he's like he's a thinner
lighter guy right you know um lot of
power he's very good athlete
but lot of power in the left
or at least he used to he used to and
that's what everybody says oh you're
you're just a a stocky wrestler with an
overhand right Conor's going to snipe
you with that left hand it's like yeah
maybe the Conor from 2018 would you know
when he was when he had his timing on he
he was more consistent he was actually
fighting trying to fight for and and get
to the titles so now he's just fighting
to get back at all so yeah are you guys
going to fight is that the question we
are going to fight and I I think right
now he's trying to wait me out I mean CU
if you were him would you want
would you want to wait as long as
possible for the guy like me who's a
real fighter who wants to be in there
who wants to compete so so that I say
screw it I'm gonna go fight someone else
and then he can go fight an easier fight
Nate Diaz he can go fight an easier
fight Tony Ferguson he can go find a
much easier fight than fighting me so I
think is now off the table Yeah I think
that's off the table and that was that
was tough to watch man cuz Tony's a
legend do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is steo butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and sto's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude